cinq ans après l'élection de françois
mitterrand à la présidence de la
république la gauche n'est plus
majoritaire il y as coexistence ou
cohabitation entre un président de
gauche un gouvernement de droite le
parti socialiste dans l'opposition au
sein du parti socialiste chacun
s'organise donnant parfois une
impression d'émiettement reportage
domique laurie alain valentini et yb
berne
il y a plusieurs demeures dans la maison
du père pourrait dire les socialistes
parisiens les résidences secondaires
dont les propriétaires s'appelle rocard
fabius chevènement mauroy cette
politique immobilière inquiète des
militants certains y voient des arrière
pensées présidentielles
pour michel rocard pas d'ambiguïté il
est installé depuis deux ans boulevard
saint germain il a annoncé clairement
son intention d'être candidat aux
élections présidentielles
tout en réaffirmant son attachement à
l'unité du ps et plus précisément ce que
fait donc michel rocard boulevard
saint-germain mon métier de député de
l'opposition
mon métier demande la direction du parti
socialiste
mon apport de réflexion et le fait
conviés tous nos camarades à se battre
ensemble sur l'idée que la politique
peut être aussi quelque chose de noble
qu'il peut y avoir une morale en
politique figurer au lendemain du 16
mars laurent fabius a installé une
antenne boulevard raspail des bureaux
prêté par la république à tous ces
anciens premiers ministres explications
insuffisantes pour certains militants
qui s'interroge laurent fabius lorsqu'il
un courant pour partir à la conquête du
pays n'ont d'ailleurs
ma position est tout à fait clair
je souhaite comme des millions de
français que françois mitterrand soit
comme des arts avenue poincaré jean
pierre chevènement l'ancien leader du
crs l'ailé gauche du parti socialiste
peaufine sa nouvelle stratégie centriste
qu'il a baptisé socialisme et république
pas d'ambitions présidentielles avoué
mais il reconnaît qu'il prépare à sa
manière l'avenir le club que j'ai créé
république moderne
n'a pas d'autre but que de définir les
perspectives d'une france forte libre
indépendante justes démocratiques pour
les 10 15 années qui viennent avenue
bosquet depuis juillet 84 pierre mauroy
se veut un homme tranquille cela ne veut
pas dire un homme sans ambition d atouts
sa complicité avec françois mitterrand
des fidèles dans le parti une image
qu'il s'efforce de moderniser sans doute
pour de futurs combats en attendant il
reçoit beaucoup je reçois mes amis de la
fédération mondiale des cités unies je
reçois des amis avec qui je fais
effectivement de la politique ce que
comme el pais le le courant b à
l'intérieur du parti socialiste je
reçois déjà bu socialiste bien sûr plus
largement et puis les collaborateurs qui
travaillent avec moi pour être complet
il faut ajouter charles hernu à
montparnasse et georgina dufoix à saint
germain mais toute cette agitation ne
semble guère préoccuper la rue de
solférino au plus un certain agacement
c'est vrai qu'il ya les succursales ou
comme jeudi les résidences secondaires
mais la maison mère c'est ici c'est là
que l'essentiel se fasse bref il s'agit
simplement de cultiver les différences
affirment ces nouveaux propriétaires
mais en toile de fond les dispositifs
mis en place cache mal certaines
ambitions présidentielles